l'ordre du jour appelle la question de
Monsieur Hilarion vandego un monsieur le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
la question s'adresse
au ministre du Budget
monsieur le ministre
nous comprenons bien que la situation
économique est difficile pour l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens et sur tout le
territoire national
naturellement il nous faut dans ce
circonstances être solidaire et croyez
bien que nous le sommes
cependant prenez connaissance le
kunrambo pour les outre-mer et
particulièrement sévère pour l'économie
canadienne
pourriez-vous néanmoins nous assurer du
maintien de la défiscalisation dans le
secteur des travaux publics du bâtiment
et notamment du logement social
activité qui génère de nombreux emplois
et soutiennent fortement l'économie
locale
merci de votre réponse à cette question
d'importance
monsieur le ministre qui même si elle
concerne plus précisément la
Nouvelle-Calédonie sera écouté avec la
plus grande attention pendant l'ensemble
des parlementaires de l'outre-mer dont
le terme groupe réunissant les 51
députés
rien d'adopter la résolution suivante
nous par le matin des Outre-mer
demandons avec fermeté que soit
maintenue les dispositifs d'un
défiscalisation actuellement à vigueur
pour l'investissement productif et le
logement social
et que soit déterminé des plafonds
attractifs en valeur absolue des
couplets du plafond global à l'instar du
dispositif Malraux
les situations économiques et sociales
des Outre-mer il est grand temps de
mettre un terme au nomadisme fiscal
et de restaurer la confiance des
investisseurs en garantissant une
stabilité
plurielle qui fait cruellement défaut
j'ai été un peu long monsieur le
ministre mais le sujet le mérite Satan
maintenant votre réponse qui je l'espère
correspondra aux attentes de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie et plus généralement
à celle des Outre-mer
merci Monsieur vandego la parole est à
Monsieur Bernard Cazenove ministre
chargé du budget monsieur le sénateur
vous avez souhaité
m'interroger sur la défiscalisation en
Nouvelle-Calédonie
sachez monsieur le sénateur que le
gouvernement est particulièrement
attaché au développement économique de
tous les territoires de la République il
est conscient que les outre-mer en
général et la Nouvelle-Calédonie en
particulier sont durement touchés par la
crise économique nous savons combien les
entreprises locales ont besoin du
soutien de l'État pour continuer à
investir à créer de l'emploi nous savons
les besoins de la population locale en
matière de logements social vous n'êtes
pas sans savoir que le redressement des
comptes de la Nation est une impérieuse
nécessité notamment pour conserver des
marges de manœuvre qui nous permettent
d'intervenir partout où cela est
nécessaire
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement porte une attention toute
particulière à l'efficacité de la
dépense publique à la suite de la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel sur
le projet de loi de finance pour 2013 le
gouvernement entamé une évaluation des
mécanismes de défiscalisation outre-mer
dans le cadre de la modernisation de
l'action publique cet évaluation a pour
but d'élaborer l'outil le plus efficient
pour honorer l'engagement du président
de la République de ne pas en avoir
avoir un euro de moins d'argent public
arrivé dans les outre-mer sans remettre
en cause ni ses objectifs ni ses
ambitions il est de la responsabilité du
gouvernement de garantir que chaque euro
dépensé au profit des Outre-mer permet
effectivement d'améliorer l'emploi et de
stimuler la croissance sur ces
territoires la construction de logements
sociaux dans les outre-mer et sur tout
le territoire et il restera un objectif
prioritaire du gouvernement
et l'État continuera à soutenir
résolument ce secteur les travaux du
gouvernement menés en concertation avec
les acteurs locaux n'ont pas encore
abouti mais comme vous le savez le
Gouvernement remettra dans le courant de
l'été au Parlement un rapport faisant le
bilan de ces travaux ce rapport servira
de base aux propositions que le
gouvernement fera en loi de finance pour
pérenniser le soutien de l'État aux
outre-mer dans l'esprit que vous avez
indiqué c'est-à-dire manifester de la
solidarité faire en sorte que l'activité
économique industrielle et en faveur du
logement puisse se poursuivre dans les
meilleures conditions
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur van
degou vous souhaitez répondre à monsieur
le ministre vous avez la parole
monsieur le ministre merci de ces
différents éléments de réponse
j'entends bien votre discours et ne
doute pas dans votre détermination
mais la Nouvelle-Calédonie ne peut se
contenter de promesses s'il vous plaît
soyez attentifs à l'application des
différentes mesures que vous préconisez
et surtout veuillez bien au suivi de son
dossier
mais je n'en doute pas un seul instant
qu'il en sera ainsi Monsieur le Ministre
si Monsieur van de gout